i'm sorry things got out of hand okay
does everything people are saying about
me isn't true i'm an actor
i'm a voice actor i'm a musician stop
the steel
what people saw yesterday was me doing
vocal exercises
me just kind of you know putting myself
out there for the first time the
industry just doesn't want
a white male unless they're literally
storming the capital you know
obviously save the children and and do a
coup
but also you know as important or even
more important
is to just try to like you know build my
socials this is my american idol this is
my the voice
i think there is a hole in the market
for sort of this like
reactionary psychopath that's also very
musical
when i first started working with q i
thought q met quincy jones
people said to me what was yesterday was
it a revolution was it a coup
uh it was an exercise in branding we
have no problem
with the capitol police by the way we
have no problem they were nice to us we
took selfies with them they let us in
uh you know we met a lot of them on
4chan sometimes i'm
sad and i feel like
there's not a space for men to share
their feelings
in this country and i think that's
tragic
i'm willing to learn and grow i've been
reading a lot of tweets about my
behavior
that are making a lot of sense to me i'm
going like back in my childhood and i'm
going
yeah yeah that was it yeah that was it
it's okay if i like to show shrill
on hulu it's my favorite show and i can
admit that like i like it because it's a
big
powerful woman that's confident and that
makes me happy
i'm the victim